أعتقد أن الجدة هي الأكثر سعادة
هناك وأعتقد أنها
تحب حقًا المرتفعات
قلعة بالمورال
الواقعة على مساحة 50000 فدان في المرتفعات الاسكتلندية
كانت الملاذ الصيفي المفضل
للملكة إليزابيث حيث
يقول الكثيرون إنها شعرت بالراحة أكثر من
صرامة المشي في الحياة الملكية
نزهات
الكلاب الكثير من الكلاب ، هناك دائمًا كلاب
وأشخاص يدخلون ويخرجون طوال
الوقت مجانًا من الخدمة العامة ،
يمكن للملكة الاسترخاء وقضاء بعض الوقت في
ركوب خيولها المحبوبة التنزه
ولعب الألعاب مثل شيراز مع
أفراد الأسرة الذين غالبًا ما يقومون بالرحلة
للزيارة  خلال فصل الصيف ، يعد Sajun
قاعدة رائعة للجدة والجد
لكي نأتي
ونراهم هناك عندما يكون لديك متسع
للتنفس والركض من
أجل كل روعة وعظمة
المساكن الملكية.
الصور كانت هناك حتى
وسادة مطرزة بكلمات
جيدة أن تكون ملكة
وقد وصفها رئيس الوزراء السابق توني بلير
في مذكراته بأنه ضعيف في
بالمور  كمزيج حيوي من
المشروب السريالي المثير للفضول
ومشروبات ما قبل العشاء الفظيعة تمامًا كانت عبارة عن
وقود صاروخي حقيقي وستقوم الملكة
بنفسها بغسل بلير ، وكتبت أنها
وضعت القفازات وألصقت أيديهم
في المغسلة تسألها الملكة
إذا انتهيت من تكديس الأطباق لأعلى وذهبت
إلى الحوض
لأطول فترة خدمة في بريطانيا ، كان للملك
بالمورال أهمية عاطفية ،
أوه ، إنه شاطئ قدمي الذي أقف
عليه حيث التقت اليزابيث الشابة
بضابط في الجيش البريطاني آنذاك والذي
سيصبح فيما بعد زوجها الأمير  فيليب
كان من الأخلاقي أيضًا أن العائلة المالكة ،
بما في ذلك الأمير هاري والأمير
ويليام ، علمت بوفاة
والدتها الأميرة ديانا
في أوقات أكثر سعادة
، كانت حفلة جيلي السنوية للعائلة المالكة بمثابة
حفلة رقص اسكتلندي منذ عهد
الملكة فيكتوريا.  أشكر الطاقم الملكي
على عملهم الشاق ،
لكن المناظر الطبيعية كانت هي التي كانت
أكثر جاذبية للملكة التي
تمشي على طول التلال المحيطة
ng الممتلكات التي تطارد
النزهات وبالطبع تقودها حول الحوزة
في الجحيم وتتجول
في مكان محبوب من التاريخ
والرمزية نهاية مناسبة لأيام صاحبة الجلالة
الأخيرة في المنزل
في بالمورال